Tracy blizzard C blizzard what's a
ghetto name that's my car was just a
platinum yeah you're clear all to Harlem
or to Brooklyn the other Brooklyn and I
see blizzards you my friend thank you no
you cry I cry what'd you buy your damn
self
I do that you'd go crazy at my food yeah
yeah you smell great
baby blue their kids birth is for me
with my money yeah that's what my
daughter I got that for my daughter
she's far she's good yeah I'm teaching
her how to ride a bike now now you are
rather she's teaching me no she knew how
to ride a bike learn how to Rada you
never learned how to ride a bike I was
too busy with Doug with the organ
grinder and the monkey on my back and
all that stuff yeah right right just
trying to you are working it well this
is what this leads me to my first
question my first real question which is
the last oh gee this is loosely question
why do X requests I'll fill out you to
District Attorney
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I do have some questions where are you I
recall recall a so on the last oh gee
this is loosely what happened what
happened to you over what about what
about a guy who is trumpet
yeah chugging it out he's what that
jumping just checking the trumpet play
out look suspicious you think mark
Pender looks suspicious yes he's been
here 25 years they need suddenly and
you've been out here many times and
you've seen him many times you always
looking at me like you a what are you
talking about made in 1962 now was 1968
but anyway yeah sorry I just know my
Planet of the Apes your I just don't
know how you got to plan to the age from
our trumpet player
[Applause]
you